si vous voulez vous déplacer dans
washington aujourd'hui ça vous prend des
bottes imperméables peut-être des
guêtres ici vous avez des enfants très
sauvage
tout ça parce que les trottoirs ne sont
pas dégagées washington comme un
débutant le nord-est des etats-unis est
pourtant équipé villes canadiennes pour
enlever la neige donc les trottoirs ne
sont pas dégager les rues les artères
principales comme celle en arrière de
moi le son ce qui fait que bien des gens
restent à la maison l'endroit où on est
ici présentement c'est un des endroits
qui est très très occupés dans ce
quartier vous voyez c'est bien désert le
capitole et fermer la maison blanche
annuler son point presse les bureaux
fédéraux les tribunaux les écoles sont
aussi fermés à washington de même que
les deux aéroports tout ça bien sûr
parce que on ne veut pas prendre de
risque on tente tranquillement d'enlever
toute cette neige là la neige pour
l'instant le finisse qui tombe c'est
plutôt de la pluie
plus tard on craint que ça retombe en
neige encore une fois donc des problèmes
additionnels new york philadelphie et
boston sont des villes dans une
situation semblable pour l'instant dans
le sud est des états unis la situation
mais les différentes c'est surtout du
verglas qui est tombé peut-être 3 4 5 cm
de verglas certains endroits donc ça
compliqué déplacements sur les routes
pour les particuliers mais aussi pour
les véhicules d'urgence et les véhicules
les entreprises d'électricité qui
tentent de réparer tous ces fils qui
sont tombés ces poteaux qui sont passés
donc bien des casse-tête dans le sud est
des états unis plus de 700 mille foyers
privés d'électricité ce matin on dit que
ça va prendre quelques jours avant de
régler tout ça pour sylla 60 aérienne
évidemment c'est aussi difficile plus de
5000 vols annulés
en fin d'avant midi au jour